you
we are back in the building we are back
on the map me and my beautiful Fender ik
we've been all been together in a while
it has been it has what happens when you
just sneak off to Florida to hang out
with Kyle for a few days oh that's it
blame it on me that's what happens in
Florida you want to San Antonio for a
little bit right I saw your Instagram oh
yeah I mean damn food stylist went down
there just crapped on the city of San
Antonio you're like hey we do we got to
write in New York okay you guys are
messed up down here I will I'm
officially having never
I got this wife one of the things she's
good for in life is showing me Instagram
the couch and then his wife goes
Christopher come over we're gonna watch
Adams Instagram stories okay that sounds
like fun yeah but I'm a New York biased
person now who you are I go to these
places and I walk and I'm like I'm in
the middle of nowhere like every place
yeah and then but everyone's a lot nicer
and then I come to New York it's like my
neighbor and they're like like all right
leave me alone all right we have a lot
to get to we're getting a long podcast I
hope not nobody as long as it's packed
with content what we're doing is Simms
spent this past weekend and last weekend
actually yeah this past weekend and he
has officially locked in the rankings of
the five quarterbacks he went back for
the first time in his analysis career
yeah in his almost feel hypocritical why
because I just feel like I've never had
to do it like there were I've had to go
look back like I hate the fact that I'm
like actually gonna change order and
stuff but I thought you said that this
year is different it is different I know
isn't the locked-in guy no and I think I
like I told you I didn't have the full
scope of film that I would like to him
the first time around so I watched but I
got to see a whole lot more are there
changes yes there's changes oh dude I
would also like to say yeah
changing rankings is something that
happens across the entire NFL Draft well
it does that's but III
I know you hold yourself to a standard
but I'm saying it's okay for you to
change your rank it definitely one that
I know that I know but but just because
I've never really had to do it at any
position really yeah it's just weird
especially a quarterback the this year
and I think also I came out so hard
because of like Bill Polian and that
crap that I was fired I just saw Lamar
Jackson I was like he's definitely a
quarterback
eat [ __ ] he's a starter so we're gonna
get to that we're gonna Phil Simms come
on I want him the New York Post put out
some favorites for Monday Night Football
and Thursday Night Football right I want
him to break down who he thinks would be
good in the booth cuz I think you guys
can scout quarterbacks and I think Phil
at this point can prick
pick broadcasters to hold on and we're
gonna bring in what what's up
who is it I got I'm on the podcast I can
hear that through my talkie I know who
is it sounds like MEMS for everybody out
there that can't hear why Christmas
talking about I was hoping he was Kyle
that's what it is okay I got you our
sourcing standards here you can go with
two people so it was important that I
had it in to that sorry thank god you're
just like chef I know I had to answer
that what was that what's the news it's
not news it's about I can't even talk
about this one actually about
quarterbacks is about the trash a little
nugget no down it's about Odell Beckham
talk about Odell we need to talk about
sue on the Rams and then we're also
gonna have our good buddy Jordan Schultz
to come on and I he's the one saying
that the Cowboys are definitely cutting
Dez I want to know more about that right
and then after we talk about sue he
talks to sue all the time I just want to
know what was sue thinking through that
whole process yeah if he can shed us
light on that
let's do 59 and why did the Jets take
the offer off the table
I still don't get that I mean I don't
understand why to save face and they
probably thought he wasn't gonna come
there but why they're like what who
cares like the Jets I were they afraid
to be embarrassed because of the Kirk
Cousins thing I mean the Curt the Kirk
Cousins and sue didn't just turn down
the Jets because they were like oh the
Jets they're horrible no there are two
guys that are at the point of their
career where okay yeah they made a ton
of money mmm so the extra two or three
million owe the Jets offered them more
than everybody else no they are that the
point of the curb where they can kind of
pick and they want to be in a position
where they can win now and the Jets have
question marks jets might be number one
in the most confusing offseason power
rankings they openly say they're gonna
pay Kirk Cousins they offer a more they
don't get them then they come out there
they trade from six to three Todd Bowles
down in Florida comes out and says well
we didn't really do this for anyone in
mind there's seven guys we like to each
everyone said well then you could have
stayed at six Todd right and now they
come out the polygon crap of course yeah
but I'm just saying a lot of mixed
messages going on the media for the end
the J et s Jets Jets Jets gotcha
fifty nine vendrick 15 nines man okay
I'm gonna go Roosevelt Colvin yes okay
like that one Danny Trevathan
yeah Wesley Woodyard yeah what else I
got what are some old 59 so Seth
Joyner let's see is there any other good
59 s like just like just there's one in
the game right now that hat even has a
chant like a cheer what he makes tackles
oh [ __ ] this hurt my heart it is yeah
okay here are the guys that you're
probably not going to know too much Nick
vigil of the Bengals Jeremiah George of
the Colts Joe Walker of the Eagles
marquise flowers Reggie Ragland you got
Woodyard you got Trevathan
d'von Dre Campbell
Witney merciless am those are Lukie holy
crap the last three I should be
embarrassed that I miss okay
some Alzheimer guys Matt Blair was a
linebacker on the Vikings in the 70s and
80s Donnie Edwards yeah linebacker the
Chargers and Chiefs attractive guy right
it was like if junior Sayal was like
five inches taller but not as good I
just Donnie Edwards was great on Madden
yes I remember apparently handsome too
D'Amico Ryan's Roosevelt Colvin dat win
Mike Mamula
Seth Joyner you're the two that you
should know yeah London Fletcher oh my
gosh they affected you that month that
did I mean especially cuz I worked with
him like I knew he was at 59 damn and
the last one is the Hall of Famer Jack
ham oh good old Jack linebacker for the
Steelers little Jack they do have a
little bit of breaking news there is a
trade in the NFL the Jaguars got
themselves a quarterback care to guess
who is gonna be backing up Blake bortles
damn I am dumb found this is why I
didn't tell you but this game damn I
haven't gone on the last one yeah okay
there has been a trade what if I told
you let me fill up the team's know that
Blake bortles is your 70th best
quarterback and to completely avoid
being told that their backup is better
than their starter they have traded for
your seventy first quarterback Cody
Kessler are you kidding me no are you I
kind of think they looked at the Simms
list they're like look he said 71 so
bortles is technically better than Cody
Kessler Blake bortles is the best
quarterback on his team now yeah I guess
so I mean a Cody Kessel we're still
throw it better than him though just so
you know just so you know do you know
what are you shocked are you what do you
feel I'm not shocked no they've
obviously are doing everything they can
not only again they made the right moves
in the offseason they've done a really
great job they really have and they've
helped his chances of even improving and
going forward yes but I'm not shocked no
we talk about this all the time I mean
it's it's the new thing in the NFL
there's no quarterbacks in the league
but we won't make any backups that are
talented to our other franchise type
quarterbacks we don't want to feel
threatened I mean
you know I eat meals that threatend then
he probably doesn't deserve to be the
starter that's that's what I was Titans
Dolphins game was the perfect example of
that last year Matt Cassel came in and
we were like you're telling me that you
you felt comfortable with this guy
because in the words a big fill right he
can break the huddle yeah and you can do
all the support he's good but then when
we get on the field yeah nothing no I
know and we talked about some the fact
that Matt Schaub is playing this long
yeah Matt Schaub great lock right but
when are we ever gonna put guys in there
to challenge the starter that's why I've
refused to hear that I say to my coach
friends sometimes too like I just don't
want to hear it don't tell me about it
it's you you guys are at fault I mean
that's you don't tell me you're the one
that lets matchup hang around for four
extra years I mean the last time you got
in the field he was like the pick-6 king
of football but he still we trust him he
play in 2008 he hit the check down and
he hit Andre Johnson he's good still
yeah okay just this drives me cry
where he gets challenged from Patrick
mahomes and he had one of his best years
last year bright because he had a young
guy chomping at the bit behind er right
I think there is some benefit it would
agree I think that carson wentz Travie
drew Bloods I mean had Drew Bledsoe and
drafted Tom Brady I mean they weren't
like oh let's get somebody that doesn't
throw it as hard as drew because we want
to make true this has been a theme of
our chauffeur
I know do you think there's an Ernie
Adams in Jacksonville who's sitting in a
room with the Sims list and just kind of
figuring out how to stack back I feel
like that's probably what the Jaguars or
any Adams is doing I don't know if there
is one there are only Adams like Bernie
Adams there are any Adams is like Tom
it's Tom Coughlin I think I guess though
I mean he's not looking at your list not
lean OTT tom is so regimented that if he
needed an Ernie Adams and he became that
guy couldn't you see him that he has
like a hat on the desk and he's like
well I should talk to Ernie I'm like
puts the hat on he goes you're right
Tommy alright great I know that all
right you were down the owners meeting I
was there you down there in Orlando it
was a late call for you you're coming
back though right Jack I'll be back in
two minutes don't you go down there you
get to hang out there leave stuff what
uh what was your big takeaway what is
the owners meeting all I see is the
coach picture right where Andy Reed
where is a floral shirt and everyone
else looks uncomfortable but what is
the event light love Andy Reid first of
all he's like guy yeah my guy but no
altogether I think the owners meaning
it's a it's a really cool event actually
it was really cool to be there basically
like the ritz-carlton they're in Orlando
Florida is overrun by the owners the
head coaches the GM's and their families
their families get to come along as well
so that's tons of kids arriving around
so but again it's it I think a chance of
course League meetings the owners are
gonna vote on things
coaches are gonna they have to go to
meetings to be informed about you know
whatever changes rules or even the state
of the league whatever they had more
meetings than they liked I can tell you
that much but again it's just a great
place to again where I think guys you
get to be around the other team's head
coaches GM's just back-channel
connections but more than anything I
think it's a chance for the teams and
their top you know their top ballers in
their organizations their head coach
their GM's their owners and some other
people to get together and spend some
quality time too and I think that's a
big thing that and you get like I said
some conversation about the trade world
and whatever it may be well they'll
stuff exactly let me ask you this so
you've talked a lot of crap about
certain people yeah any awkward model I
certainly I mean one of my biggest fears
walking into that hotel on Monday
morning I was like Tim there's a few
coaches that might not like me I mean
aka the Jacksonville Jaguars I thought
about men you know my man Caldwell down
there yeah he might see me and the
things I've said about Seattle's yes and
I said hello to him he said like hey
Chris and then I feel like he was like
why did I say hey I saw Mike McCarthy
which you've always slimmed their office
I slammed their offense and I even told
some green ba people there I did say
this to them fought out I was like yeah
I slam your offense I'm sorry I was like
I really like Mike McCarthy the head
coach he's a good head coach I just said
sorry I just said I and that was it but
I feel like he was a guy that like when
he saw me he was like he looked the
other way he didn't want to need any
conversation or friendly banter that I
know you guys had like a big like dinner
thing on Monday they have like a
gathering on Monday night on like the
lawn of the
hotel and again the kids wives are there
the kids are there so not only is there
like screens of like NFL stuff but on it
was like a huge lawn there was two huge
screens of like a kid movie plug yeah
and they had like a white picket fence
around it so like the kids are locked in
there to watch the movie but but yeah
kind of cocktails food stations yeah
things like that a chance to mingle yeah
and it really was cool it really was
it's good to hang out Kyle I got to hang
out with Kyle I got to see so many old
friends and old faces it was truly great
like whether it was brian glazier the
owner of the tampa bay buccaneers I
haven't seen the Glazer family in a
while for them to come over say hello
you know see Mike Tomlin talk to him
how's he doing
Mike T is the man I mean he really is I
just how do you guys talk about when
you're hanging out with Tom gosh he's
just he's just a man's man
and we talk I mean he's a he was a talk
boss so what kind of questions does he
ask you he doesn't ask me a whole lot
it's just really kind of I it's it
wasn't like we were one-on-one if you
were like you're like Sean Davis I knew
he was in college I mean what's the deal
with that clock management at the end of
the Patriots game Tom no all right Mike
T I feel like the kind of guy that like
would know that I might have like been
critical of that and he doesn't care and
yeah he'll make his own comments in his
own way I'm gonna keep those private to
where like I felt like he was like
referring a few times like hey I heard
what you said
oh really yeah every what you said but
you ain't in my shoes in the name as
easy as you think that's basically like
which I respect it what was it like
seeing your your old stepdad my old
stepdad yeah Jon Gruden
was awesome seeing JJ jeez there's Jon
Gruden and Jason Garrett sigh I say I
call them both J Jarrett's like the
nicest guy ever but it's like Chris can
I get you a drink
literally I mean almost is that nice
that's why I think people don't like him
in dalehite it's too nice hey I would
agree to a degree it but Gruden I want
to hire Rudin I mean the man I mean
Gruden
he's wearing his white collared shirt
really you were that the whole time I
think he did the same shot three days
buttons are unbuttoned he's walking
around a little gold chain and has a
playbook with him
this is the thing I found interesting
and I don't think he cares that I'm
gonna share this you know we have we
have good laugh good talks we talked
about some things in the draft and I
can't share all that but though Sims is
getting mad chef Tiana's there's some
things I gotta keep private because then
John Gunes not gonna talk to me ever
again and then I won't have anything to
ever share on the podcast but you know
the one thing I learned from John and I
think he'll have no issue talking about
this is the simplifying of his offense I
think there was a really cool combo
because he basically went around you
know he's been doing TV for the last 110
years and you know between the fact that
of course he has a relationship with his
brother and Kyle Shannon and McVeigh and
they have found ways to simplify his
robbing yeah and of course he's taking
to account he's going around to colleges
and seeing some of these college kids at
the QB Gruden camp and all that he's
learning their language and he's also
realizing like receivers are not on the
same level that used to be as far as
knowing offenses this was your big
question about Gruden would he adjust
and this is what so he's adjusting first
you could tell oh I know he to tell if
it was hard on him well this is why he
was he was carrying around the playbook
because he's sitting in these meetings
quizzing himself so he can continue to
learn the language cuz he's had one
language he's known his whole life yeah
so you gonna understand this it's like
okay he's been an expert in Spanish
other as his second language now he's
created now she's trying to exactly
right and now it's like so he's gotta
get it in his brain so he can spit it
out when he wants man I thought that was
really interesting and I think you know
he's got in mind not only free agents
coming there so they can pick it up
quickly but the draft kids and of course
teaching it and he's going absolutely
insane you could tell already oh he's
going it's the first thing he said to me
oh I don't know I'm just just waiting to
when I can meet my quarterback and like
who teach him the offense you know he
just wants to get in he's going insane I
mean he's going I guess I knew John
himself but he needs to teach that
that's gonna help him teach himself and
he wants to just get on the field and
see his players and man some of these
guys he's got a he's got a draft to
worry about so he's got to see can this
guy retain stuff and where's all the
power right now yes you know all the
moves that are
it's no longer Reggie McKenzie no I
would say John has yes right when you
get a 10-year hundred million dollar
contract right I don't think you have
the biggest voice no doubt about it and
I think you know even if you look at
their introductory press conference I
mean they kind of alluded that Reggie
was kind of like I'm gonna work with
John his team see with his vision that's
honestly how it should it should be
that's what they did in Seattle right
Schneider and Carroll work together
exactly who's the who's the big dog
Bill Belichick now he doesn't go to the
photo Bill Bell I don't know why is that
bill does whatever he wants first of all
it's really funny to have to see NFL
head coaches have to be on meetings that
are not their own right because they
don't get there on time you know a
Monday morning brunch and I see like I'm
doing the show on pro football yeah NBC
and it's like 7:45 and I know the
breakfast started at 7:00 and I'm seeing
our parade of coaches just walk by like
oh what Russian like doing their tires
their yeah who's the most stylish coach
ooh wait were you gonna go more
Belichick that wasn't a go Belichick
well just because like this is one story
Belichick is he's the Godfather of
course there's no doubt I mean he's the
man it's got a handful of angles but I
had a I had I heard like at that little
gathering on Monday night there was some
coaches or a telling story about
Belichick walking into one of the
meetings they were the coaches mean it
was like a meeting yeah it's like a
State of the Union this is what's going
on in league whatever it may be and that
this there was a speaker up there but
nobody liked that we would know the name
of right this was just the guy that was
gonna talk about this one area of the
NFL and the story is that a few of my
coaching friends they were talking about
I was just listening but basically
Belichick walked in the meeting like 15
minutes late and he's got you know his
huge backpack on which he's always carry
and the guys in mid you know explaining
what it is and Belichick walks in and as
he's getting to his seat the guy's
telling the story and he goes I don't
know if I agree with that and the Kuwait
away the coaches are saying he's not
even looking at this guy's to talk but
he's raising his hand going this is how
they were bred I don't know if I agree
with that and he starts giving up now
without even looking and he's still
unpacking his bag and say he's arguing
the points the guys making and they were
laughing basically because they said the
speaker got all flustered was like
that's a good point we'll get back to
that then it just tells you what you
three once what and he's just out of
this world brilliant that's what I'm
saying what you said there that I love
is this is my theory right really
intelligent people are really bad at eye
contact right really bad right the
people that I meet that are brilliant
cannot look me in the eyes yeah you look
me right in the eyes yep I'm pretty
stupid
yeah let's say this to Annie Reed
yeah coaching tree yeah think about this
uh-huh Peterson hardball in Baltimore
Rivera McDermott Nagy Shermer and Bowles
Andy and his tree make up a quarter of
the league now so we've always talked
about all these quarterback these
coaching coaching trees one-fourth of
the NFL is Andy Reed and his assistants
amazing and you can even add and like
you you could semi almost like give Jon
Gruden like a limb of that tree is that
all go under home great goes all under
home reigning yes well but those guys
took coached under read like right name
culture in was Holmgren Mary Mariucci
was her Yugi was right but Reid was the
offensive coordinator so they were all
under him but but yes it is amazing all
right let's talk O'Dell oh let's talking
so so many rumors about Odell we got
into it before but now is where it's
getting interesting
yeah shefter came out today we were
doing this on a Wednesday yeah Giants
are looking for at least two first
rounders for Odell even though the team
denies shopping him shefter also said
today quote I would not be shocked if we
see an Odell Beckham trade on or before
the draft that matters to me because
these news breakers don't like to get
scooped right and if they know that they
think a trades gonna happen they're
going to say I'm feeling like
something's gonna happen so that when it
does they can go yeah but like I warned
you guys two weeks ago yes what is your
percent that you think Odell gets traded
I think it's 50/50 Wow I'm gonna say
right at the line I think so I mean I
think it could go either way I mean do
you think a team would give up to
first-round picks for Odell yeah I do
would you I think I'll tell you this I
told you this beforehand
if I'm it's the right team the money
situation again it's the two first
rounds is rich it really is because you
have to take an account you have to sign
him to a twenty million dollar country
giving up your future Ryan you're giving
up a like huge you're gonna give up like
percent of your entire salary cap
exactly right exactly right so you were
kind of making in the face of your
franchise yes you already have a face
and we've already talked about there is
no face more famous rodell's face right
and I think what's funny too let's just
visit this real quick is the timeline of
this conversation okay so first of all
it comes out that he's he could be
traded right no nobody's untouchable and
John Mara makes those comments on Sunday
when he first got to leave like it was
after the JP Petri right here like this
and I'm sick of talk answering questions
about 100 morning Rappaport reports that
Odell is not gonna step foot on the
field that's next so there's the next
thing that's his way of fighting back
yes now the Giants go well our main
concern is we'd like to resize him and
do they're saying things like he's on
the roster gentleman comes out and they
ask about that like really we're I do
goes all I saw was the pizza right they
kind of said all these things to get on
his side right and then Merrick came out
later and was like we're not doing this
I don't want to answer questions about
him being traded now yes because I think
that my my my connecting dots on that
conversation would be that they got a
flood of phone calls and they were like
oh my gosh we from the rest of the NFIB
he's better than we think he actually is
you say that you had a lot of people
asking what I did well you know yes
somewhat like that of course was a huge
conversation so it just came up all the
time the Odell thing like coaches are
coming to me like what have you heard
about them in the law I had some coaches
definitely asked me like hey do you know
anything about him I know you know the
Giants and they don't need the players
what do they say about him so that's
where I can offer something doing a
little bit of tests in the water yeah
they just want to figure out what the
guy is right so I told them and of
course you I know you know some things
and and but but really the things you
hear from players and this is I have
more than four players that have told me
about Odell Beckham jr. as a player in
the locker room he's loved
I mean it's unanimous the players loved
Odell Beckham jr. I mean just to throw
out a few names whether it was Justin
Pugh or Brandon
Marshall right and the list is longer
than that along with other people in the
Giants organization that I know really
like Odell Beckham jr. so my thing is
that I think they got a flood of phone
calls and they went oh my gosh okay wait
you don't want to trade them and then I
think they also thought about whoa okay
well now we have to raise the stock
price and that's where today it becomes
the two first rounders because we're not
actually looking because there's they
realize there's an actual legit market
and then what came into the conversation
that I found the most cool about the old
evident you know me I put myself out
there with comments all the time that's
what I do and not to make one no just
this private conversation with coaches
again and I had a few just go like you
know it came up and I just said I don't
know I just had listened to me Odell
Beckham jr. it's like I'm not even lying
guys I said he's the greatest receiver
I've ever seen and yeah I had like
multiple head coaches like agree with
that statement like god I'm not gonna
argue there multiple head coaches the
NFL agreed with your take that it's the
best receiver that you've ever seen in
your life yes yes what are their name I
can't tell you that man but yes I mean
you know me I throw around that comment
all the time so it came up a few times
over their two-day period whereas I get
he's the greatest I've ever seen that
key he's the greatest route runner he's
the best after the catch he's phenomenal
50-50 ball guy for a guy that's what 511
six foot and out of the fact this is
what I always tell imagine if he was in
an offense that actually moved his
position or did something with him other
than run a go router a slant well at 11
personnel right I mean what would he do
and some of the creative offenses that
know how to use him so that's where I
that's where I always say to other
coaches or GM's or other friends that I
know so like it comes out today we're
not actually shopping him but the cost
has to first-rounders what what is your
how do you think this goes like where
does it go from here I think at the end
of the day
Hodel by the way I see a video on TMZ
right of him dancing to a song and it
says like leave me alone which we're
reading too much into him dancing to a
song yeah but listen Hodel do my game
plan put out a video of you work it out
tomorrow okay that's what we need from
you workout videos yeah but how do you
think this whole thing unfolds I
got the end of the day if he just made
me bet I just think the price of what
they're asking I think the fact that he
loves New York
mmm I just think he'll still end up
staying here in need with the New York
Giants and they're gonna find a way to
give him a long-term contract though my
bet one of the main things we're getting
tweeted right now is tell Chris yeah to
call Kyle and trade for Odell yeah well
get him with Jimmy Garoppolo that would
be awesome I guess trust me I said that
to Kyle exact to as I go to a Beckham
jr. and your offense you got together I
was like I think he's better than Julio
and he looked at me and I was like yeah
I said that I think he's better than
Julio what do you say Wow okay you know
but yeah I mean that's why it's just I
played out said it to Kyle cuz I was
like damn you got Jimmy Garoppolo you
you guys have money to spend so it makes
save a ton of sound right right but he's
not gonna tell me those kind of things
that's not where our no and again I
don't want to know those things from
Kyle I've told you this like this was it
Kirk Cousins Jimmy Garoppolo thing that
one came out [ __ ] right I know yeah
that story came out yeah he was actually
because Kyle like yeah you know yeah you
just knew that I know I know Kyle so I
think I think he's getting traded I
think he's gonna train it's your bet I
think that I think that someone's gonna
come for I think if somebody traded a
first third and a seventh for Percy
Harvin yeah I didn't think I get to
first for Odell I think that don't this
is the thing that I don't understand
right oh it's all this distraction oh
we're gonna be paying them all this
money the amount of merchandise and
sales and ticket sales and all that that
you get from having Odell just if I'm
running a business I I feel like that
outweighs the salary like I feel you pay
him 20 million a year but I feel like
Odell brings in the franchise 50 million
a year yeah if not more right I just
think from a business it's too good and
also like man if you can get a motivated
Odell Beckham jr. upset against the New
York Giants yes I want him on my team
and Gabe is over here just me and and
yeah I would say this may be the Super
Ball has softened me up but if if the
New York Giants and Odell can't figure
this out and Odell has to go somewhere
else I really feel bad for Giants fans
because truly it's be the it would be
the ego and the lack of self-discipline
of the Giants organization for them to
not be able to handle all the questions
and not be able to handle it
I always thought players couldn't handle
the Big Apple but apparently the Giants
can't handle having a famous player in
the Big Apple yeah and that's what I
don't understand I got you with all
these quarterbacks Josh Rosen might talk
too much to be in the big city really
well it's your job as a franchise and
put a structure around them so that
they're protected right and I to me it
just seems like the organization
themselves this this city's too big for
them last thing I'll say on this subject
let's just not forget this everybody out
there Odell Beckham jr. has power in
this trade this whoever traits room they
have to know that Odell Beckham jr. his
agent are willing to sign a long-term
contract if they're not like if the
Cleveland Browns call go we'll give you
our next five first-round picks and he
goes that's great but I'm only gonna be
there for one year I'm not staying long
term with you that's never gonna happen
it really does feel like a big home run
hitter being traded like the MLB
deadline or like a big time scorer at
the NBA it's like you could get it for a
long-term deal but you're not giving up
all that for one season man this is
right I don't think he's gonna step on
the field if he doesn't I don't think so
either that's right I look at the Giants
this is another very I think they
dropped the ball like when he got hurt
last year that's exactly when they
should have offered him a long-term deal
like offered him like 18 million a year
going forward even though you got hurt
we still love you here's the cards your
money and we're gonna get you it for
like two million dollars less a year sue
goes to the Rams I am
unbelievable you came out right away and
you said look in Donegan sue aaron
donald the best dt duo
in NFL history and i've read some of the
comments underneath that i was just
shocked with how many people disagreed
with that I just I don't know in shock
that you wouldn't read the kind I don't
know why I did but I scrolled down and I
was like wait people don't think that
and then what's funny it's all sue
everyone thinks that Susan I know and
then when I what's funny though is when
the trade happens I go on nfl.com or
yeah ESPN where maybe the greatest
defensive tackle duo ever and I want to
be like what so I'm gonna read you some
duos that people tweeted at us that they
said we're better you tell me if they
are
okay Mike Mik Mikkel ref yeah SAP and
McFarland are the best duo ever period
negative Ghost Rider oh good one but
even on the field together that much
Beansie k77 false Kevin and Pat Williams
hashtag skull come on I mean they're
good they're really awesome but I mean
we're talking about like just go ahead
keep going eeek pump Sam Adams and Pat
Williams with Buffalo big big guys but I
mean you're gonna put Pat William I mean
just think of these names were talking
about Rob Williams been here twice this
is from Darby Greene Merlin Olsen and
rosey Grier best tackle duo have a
pretty good one I can't say that I've
sat there and studied the film of those
two Four Horsemen of the lnos they were
awesome yes maybe I mean that had to be
a that had to be an old man older man
then sent that one and maybe you've been
watching the 75 to 78 Raiders because
Shea real Shea 307 submitted Otis
Sistrunk and Ted Hendricks
Otis Sistrunk and Ted that's awesome
people are coming at you with some fire
duo's man they are good they're not
wrong do you think we have this as a
society a weird view of sue why is this
guy that was drafted third came in was
like an all-pro immediately he became
known Ettore ously for stepping on
people and being a little bit dirty and
because of that he has been given this
thing where we don't look we neglect his
talent and only look at his demeanor
right I just don't understand how people
can't see what he does every game is
special yeah is because he had four and
a half sacks last year but they don't
realize the [ __ ] the play ups tests I
don't I do think that there's a huge
part of that yes and the fact that he
just kind of been he was up in Detroit
he got lost in the shuffle up there they
weren't very good they couldn't get in
the playoffs and they blame him for that
he's stepping on people's calf muscles
and you know body slam in certain
quarterbacks and doing that stuff but
again what year are we in this what year
is this for Adamic ensue
I'm gonna pull this up right now I'm a
little he came out here I think 2009 I'm
getting to announce 2010 2010 zazz with
you 10 okay so I'm just gonna put it
this way I mean we all it sounds like
everybody knows that Aaron Donald's the
man but I'm just gonna try to explain
that in Dominic ensue was the Fletcher
Cox or the Aaron Donnell the football
before these two came along I mean hence
the reason he got a hundred and fifteen
million dollar contract for the Dolphins
they didn't give him that contract cuz
they were like damn you're pretty
average we're gonna give you a hundred
and fifteen if you were good we would've
gave you 130 so he was unblockable human
being I mean unblockable he is truly one
of the most unblockable man to man d
tackles the sport has ever seen and like
you said it comes up to the just [ __ ]
the play upstairs and there is no stat
for that but I would say from 2010 11 12
13 and really 14 before he got paid by
the Dolphins he was without a doubt
everybody out there without a doubt the
number one interior defensive lineman in
football and was definitely in the
conversation for the best defensive
player in football hands down so that's
why I say it's the greatest of all and
then he went to the Dolphins and isn't
it as good that we won no but it's still
awesome he's being held to a standard
that I think's a little unfair so
apparently they're gonna be playing this
three four is sooo playing the nose now
it's like because that kind of negates a
lot of his best abilities I thought yeah
but he can do both and it's not a true
nose they don't play a true 3/4 okay
like the nose tackle doesn't go head up
a house Donald and Sue gonna line up I
think I think they could be one of those
it depends on the strength of the
formation where I don't necessarily look
at it and go oh I think Wade Phillips is
gonna make and dhama can sue the shade
doz and Aaron Donald the three technique
no I think that that could be wrote the
strength of the offense is on the left
side Donald might be the three technique
to that side and Donald's this but the
strengths to the right side you might
see Donald of the three technique I also
get the family sue at the three and
Donald of the nice feeling too because
when you look at their D line bra curves
is probably the third best D lineman
including defensive ends yeah I could
see all three of those guys playing
together put all three of the line good
luck running yeah they do know and then
figure out who you're put on the other
right right and then let Donald and Sue
do the pass rush they could do the pass
rush and let's not forget wade phillips
is a very creative Blitzer is
well so he's probably not as concerned
with having the outside edge guy when he
has these two and again I just will say
it one more time to me the value of
interior pass rush I think is starting
to finally be seen more and more
throughout the NFL they're starting to
go wait the hell with the guys getting
on the out in the edge all the time
quarterbacks are really screwing up and
making bad decisions when they have
people in their face
joining Aaron Donald is endemic and Sue
Marcus Peters Aqib Talib write better
defense Jaguars or rims I'm still gonna
go the Jags better defense Eagles or
Rams hmm I'm gonna go the Rams better
defense Rams are Vikings yeah are the
Rams now the second best defense in the
NFL yeah that's close that Rams Vikings
one is close I'm gonna say that they are
Wow okay so they're up there they are up
there because the thing we're forgetting
you know what I think I think LaMarcus
joiners awesome yes okay and Wade
Phillips and Wade Phillips is awesome
let's give Jordan Schultz a call back
there let's dial him up let's see what
he's got to say mister energy we're
gonna limit him a little bit just
because that man can go yeah and we got
a call big and big Phil okay yeah I just
think the whole you know it feels a
little dream team II do you think that
they could mesh together right away this
is one thing I glad you just brought
this up again I'm very I think it's very
smart on the Rams hold on what's one
second I think it's very smart in the
Rams to only sign him to a one-year deal
so they'd be more on out so keep him
motivated also he's signed him to a
three-year deal and he is a locker room
cancer then that cancer can spread
throughout the locker room if he's there
for more than one year this is gonna be
a good trial period prove it thing and
he should be on his best behavior
behavior cuz II don't want to sign a
long term after this if there's one guy
that's gonna know what he's really like
as a human it's gonna be our guy Jordan
Schultz mr. Schultz how you feeling pal
lesbian Chrissy
all right Souls men you were with Chris
and I saw him the guy was so
disrespectful to me in front of multiple
people
in what way what do we do well I you
know I and you know he's got he's got
somebody with them you know buddy it is
and you know he just starts you just
start calling me out for a multitude of
things and the only reason I'm doing
this is the stupid podcast because I
Adam thank you that's very nice thank
you you know what I call them out about
what I I can't remember how the contacts
went but I was like don't you worry I
know what your apartment looks like and
that's pretty dope in New York City
Jordans the man he's got great kids got
a great wife he's the man he's great
Jordan you are seemingly in my mind the
Northwest American reporter where anyone
that comes from that region Jordan knows
and I feel like you've been talking with
sue a long time you kept America abreast
of a situation giving updates when he
was in Tennessee in New Orleans why do
you think he ended up with the Rams and
what do you think when you hear people
saying that he could be a cancer for
that locker room clearly with an
opportunity to contend fellas which is
something we know he hasn't had an
opportunity to do in both Miami in
Detroit he he's from Portland he was I
think certainly enthused by the fact
that he could play close to home be on
the west coast LA presented an
opportunity to pursue opportunities
beyond football and he he felt like his
visit that he immediately connected with
the staff so that's John McVay that
quest me the GM and and maybe most
importantly Wade Phillips
the defensive coordinator right we told
them you know we're gonna move you
around because listen this is a three
four
it's a non-traditional three four though
and of course you can speak more this
time than than me but his ability to
play on the nose right opposite ear and
Donald they also michael Brocker is
there so he you liked the idea of being
you know moved around and being
versatile yeah where he didn't have to
always be double team which has
certainly been an issue throughout his
career right Aaron Donald's really is
that good and I think lastly you know
just
culture of the of the building he felt
really comfortable there all right
so you were just Simmons was just
talking about the threefold stuff but I
to me it kind of feels a little Durante
and that's what I've tried to said to to
said to you Simmons about Durant is
here's a guy in Sioux who's had to carry
the weight of every franchise as d-line
he's had to go to and now he's going
you're telling me I get to ball with
another baller right and finally I get
to get some single games it's still not
as bad as Durant okay I mean he wasn't
on the team that had they had them down
3-1 okay I didn't join the greatest team
we've ever seen in the sport so sorry I
know it's a tough point for him sure
right exactly right he did like I
thought the whole way or after the Rams
I felt like they they had taken the lead
in this thing and I'm I don't think he
would have gone to New York anyway even
if they hadn't oh yeah what happened
with that Schultz what how about the
whole jet situation well he they came in
late he was he has visited Tennessee New
Orleans and in LA New Orleans first in
Tennessee the Rams and the Jets came in
late and and there were Dallas was
interested you know Seattle was
interested that there were other teams
interested but yet without actually
making a visit said you know we're gonna
offer you a tremendous amount of money
and here's how we're going to use you
and they sent him you know a series of
texts of basically and Todd Bowles was
involved with this here's how we
envisioned envisioned using you in our
three four which is dimmer than Wade
Phillips is and he was intrigued because
it was New York he likes hot bowls but
when they rescinded the offer I think
you know that kind of brought him back
to square one but I don't I I never
really got the sense he was going in New
York how much bigger was the Jets offer
than that one year 14 that he got with
the Rams
you know I'm perfectly honest I don't
know exactly what the shopper was other
than the fact that it was significant it
was bigger than the other three and that
it was it was big enough to where it was
like
each one of those three teams knew
without question that if it came down to
just money they had no chat schultzy and
you don't have to answer this but I'd
like you to who came in second you think
behind the Rams like what was the next
team he was thinking let you know who do
you think it came down to I I felt like
of course he did and and he connected
with you know that damn Jordan he did
not see on the visit but who we liked a
lot right yeah him was child Rankin's
yeah but then again he also was like you
know Tennessee made a great impression
you know obviously Mike graybles their
new head coach you know there was a lot
of synergy there yes Harvey today one of
the other I I don't know I you're the
same gut you're just saying gut feeling
you felt like it was the Saints for a
second you there yeah no I got one more
for you then you need to keep us
up-to-date
the Cowboys go they get Allen Hurns and
now there's talk from you that the
Cowboys are getting ready to possibly
move on from Dez what are you hearing
well there's a post you one cut that
that's what happened with sue as an
example well that's what Miami did with
him and it allowed him to explore other
options and that's what Crabtree got
with the Raiders and that's how he was
able to sign with Baltimore before the
wide receiver markets right up and I
bring up Crabtree because I just don't
understand what Dallas frankly hasn't
caught him yet but he said he has 16 and
a half million dollar cap it and he's
somebody that we know is not the Dez
Bryant that he was three four years ago
he's not he's not anywhere close today I
mean again Christmas more depth through
this time neva be anywhere near what he
was no no you're you're spot-on if I
thought you were totally wrong I would
have butted in and told you to shut up
you're right Schultz would right here
and then that you can guarantee that
he's getting cut I was told yesterday
and then getting reaffirmed by a veteran
executive was that I would Dallas but
was that there's just no way considering
they did assign her and her does not I
mean he's he's a good player right Brett
yes your number one guy but there's just
no way considering what they have coming
up with Elliott and dak they're gonna
ultimately feel like they can keep him
now I don't know why because they could
designate it now as opposed to you want
and they could cut them right a little
strength that they haven't done yet but
what I was told from two different
people now is that there's just it you
know the ability for them to keep its
ability for them to keep DES and and the
sensibility of it is just nuts and that
after the draft assuming they get that
our guy Calvin really from Alabama in
nineteen especially and that would make
sense after the draft and maybe there is
some insurance of keeping him before but
I just don't think there's a situation
where he ultimately ends up playing in
Dallas next year right Schulte you're
the man bro I appreciate you dude and
I'm gonna beat sims's ass for you well
you know Chrissy I appreciate that love
you bud
that's that Schultz's number-one insult
yeah you're bad guy I like came out to
him one time and I like he could say
well everyone so I'll set the record
straight what happened okay we were
talking he was talking to somebody else
I kind of but it in the car said what's
up
he said hey I'm in the middle of
something right here can I can i come
find you later and he texted me like an
hour later like where you at I was like
I'm not far from where I saw you the
last time and I never heard from again
so he's fooling around
so I get the Dez Bryant thing yeah what
do you think I think that sounds like
he's reading some tea leaves there well
yeah I'm sure he is for some good info
there but I think the big thing is just
he's yeah I don't know if the Cowboys
truly know yet they might be trying to
go alright so who else can we get at the
position before we do then that's what
makes sense we'll write and see what
they do in the draft exactly so I think
there's a few things that play out maybe
they feel like maybe they can get a
low-level trade something like that that
he would sign a new deal with somebody
else whatever it may be I think they're
just exhausting all their options but I
think at the end of the day I'm with you
I think it will end up or what schultzy
said being designated as a post
joong-won cut which then takes the dead
money from 8 million to 4 million right
and that's easier to deal with do you
want to call your dad now yeah okay
let's do it let's just do it it's call
Phil Simms we're gonna talk some
broadcasting right now and then Seymour
should we just tease this quarterback
thing to the next step no and then Chris
Simms is doing his new updated
quarterback rankings I wrote went
through your notes I got them all down
you know yeah we're gonna talk to Phil I
don't hear you and my earphones right
now do you know know you're Phil I don't
know is anybody there you guys hearing
me okay I don't hear you my earphones
Phil yeah I have no life I just sit
around and just wait for the phone to
ring and whenever y'all feel like
calling me just call me you know that's
what it is the best part is job gets
better every week we know you have no
life stop stating that I mean I just
talked to you on the phone and you were
working out I mean you know we didn't
talk about today Adam you and I should
just talk and let's talk about all the
peculiar things about my son Christopher
all right interesting interesting let's
do it well first off his diet my god
right I agree what stands out to you
about his diet does he ever give in and
like take your suggestion or do it your
way or is it always
to be his way no I I get him quite a bit
big Phil I'd really yeah well you know
as the work wife what says what I say go
that's one thing I've learned about the
Sims family is that you know if the wife
speaks up you guys just back down say
that to us as the kids he used to say
that to us he'd be like well you know
hey don't forget kids your mom and you
you're blood I'm the blood to her I just
figured you know he treated you just
like he treats us at him but I guess he
treats you a little better you know I
have a quite special big phil big so our
special brother what's going on what are
not today let's see I think you're an
expert in two things quarterback play
and broadcasting and there's a lot of
shake ups right now too in teaching oh I
saw I saw you teaching Brandon Wimbush
in an old video and I really enjoyed it
it was in the the field right behind
your house boys like the first time ever
yeah probably to report and I remember
meeting him and going wow I he was gonna
be a junior that year going into his
junior year I said hey man if you ever
want to throw you know let me know and I
always was hoping he would call me and
he should have called me oh yeah he
needs the call cuz I saw the video too
and he doesn't throw it the way he was
throwing in that video a deal like I
mean and of course he's gonna get
benched at Notre Dame for a kid that can
throw the ball better than him so yeah
it Brandon would bish is out there the
Sims are offering free lessons once
again I love it I got a lot of my son
Matt and I we know we're talking with
quite a few kids and and as I say to
some yeah what took so long it's too
late you know it's too late you know
let's all well I'm gonna be a senior huh
Yeah right can I get a freshman yeah one
time yeah you're right it's always
adverting disaster now I need me I I
have no other Avenue help me out oh
great okay no oh by the way for both of
you
we got a ton of tweets and I got some
text saying that when Chris called into
the podcast on Monday he talks on the
phone
just like big Phil talks you guys sound
the same on the phone gosh I you know
I've never really had anybody tell me we
sound the same and I sure as hell don't
we don't say the same thing so okay
that's the owners meeting you know I was
wondering some of those I was watching
what so good and you know some of these
coaches come on and probably look at
Christopher going man you just crushed
my ass during the season here I will
talk to you dad I was we already had a
conversation about this in the podcast
there were certain coaches there I was
like oh I got a dump ready to block his
right jab just in case it comes here a
little to the right stay away from the
big I need your broadcasting analysis
number one are you surprised that Peyton
Manning turned down ESPN and Fox you
know it was written about so much I
thought he was going to take one you
know you know you don't for him I'm glad
he didn't mmm right you know man well
why does he want to get into this this
world he doesn't have to he wants to run
a team on a team that type of thing the
problem is there's just no teams out
there uh perhaps right Carolina Panthers
of course but we see that price tag but
you know I would think that's what
Peyton hang would really like to do so
to go into broadcasting then have to
listen to what everybody says all that
and then to go to meetings and well you
know I don't I don't want to say it's
beneath me
well yeah that's you know that's what
you used to say it is beneath them I
happen Yeah right it really is right
whatever you know a fanbase is gonna
hate him they're gonna hate the way he
says something this all that's right he
talks about Tom Brady missing one throw
away look he's hating on Tom Brady see
it doesn't like Tom that's right right a
lot of his contemporaries are out there
right he played with so it's kind of
hard to go out there and really be
honest and and all that stuff so yeah
you know good for him I'm glad he didn't
take it yeah so big Phil the New York
Post put out a list of possible color
commentators for Thursday Night Football
you have covered all of these guys
you have been in meetings with all of
these guys and they're undoubtedly that
the guy on the team that when you'd to
speak to one player they were the ones
being mentioned and I'm curious these
are the names that they've said which
one stick out to you Oh Kurt Warner
Jason Witten Joe Thomas Greg Olsen
Carson Palmer hmm that's what the New
York Post put out so apparently they
enjoyed the Tony Romo experiment of
taking a guy right from the league and
put them in the booth of those five
names Kurt Warner Jason Witten Joe
Thomas Greg Olsen Carson Palmer which
one we know which one you like you know
like all of them can be good we know
that so we're not trying to sit here and
say in any of those all right so which
one do you think out of those groups I
got the guys you talk to you just think
like oh I do like him I think he could
be the easiest one just because he
played quarterback knows a lot about you
know it's all quarterbacks do you know a
little bit about everything right and
the game is through the quarterback down
that's all they talk about and you
wouldn't lose by your quarterback you
gotta have a franchise quarterback and
is he the man he's got to make the next
step you know on and on and on but you
know so and he's been in broadcasting so
he gets a little he would be he would
definitely have the easiest transition
right no the other guys I don't know I
don't know him well enough to say about
you know Greg Olson yeah we'll say is
yes great personality and fun to be
around right maybe more than all the
guys you talked about I think all right
then and he wants to do it I could you
know you can sense it in him yep he
loves the sport and you know Christopher
we did Hey look they all grew up right
by us right across the highway here
promise yeah real quick story I'm
throwing footballs with his brother is
going to go to dinner they want to Notre
Dame right Chris Olson yes and Greg is
catching footballs pouring that day
every work in and we're throwing one in
Greg's left field I'm going damn what
year is he he's still in high school
like I was so couldn't get over him how
fast he was and how easy made it look
and there was a coach there that day
from USC watching him because they came
to see Greg Olson and Chris Olson the
quarterback I'm working but I saw the
ball well he goes is
the quarterback that I just watched on
tape in there I said yeah goes Manny
they look like he does I said well
that's good that's what we want we want
change him but there was Lane Kiffin
standing there watching to work out
watching Greg Olson and just going oh my
god USC so this I I even even that day
as a junior in high school I knew he was
an absolute Pro just watched him that
day brownie kiss football right that's a
cool story yeah yeah it was cool I
really was you know the Olson family
their legends up here in this area and
their yeah their dad made Vince Lombardi
look like you know choirboy yeah I know
I line once and gloated and he sent
somebody out there tell me if I did it
again he's gonna break my leg I got one
more broadcasting thing for you the New
York Post Post also put out the Monday
Night Football list
similar Kurt Warner Matt Hasselbeck
Lewis Riddick Randy Moss and Greg Olson
but there's one long shot and I want to
know if Phil Simms thinks it's possible
the long shot is Brett Favre any chance
that you think Brett is getting in the
booth and also would he be good in the
booth you know I will root for Brett
Favre to take that job and do it me too
it will be a much listen no TV etiquette
I'm sure there's no way he's gonna watch
it and you know try to be well I don't
want to say uh he would be
unprofessional but I don't think he
would really like say oh I'm gonna just
dig into this game and learn everything
about it right right that's not far yeah
it's like Brett Favre drive it to the
championship game the first Super Bowl
they want it was raining I think they
played San Francisco up in Green Bay
it's just an awful day that's the second
championship game today go ahead so that
was the second championship game the San
Francisco one
Gotti had a nickname for his father I
think it's something like Rockhead yeah
was it something like that you're right
yeah if you saw my father you'd go okay
that did seem right so they're sitting
there quiet in the car and the father
turns to him and goes what do you think
you'll have to change the game plan a
little today because of the weather and
bread turns to him and goes hey Dad who
gives a damn I hope airs and just like
didn't want to call any football didn't
care about the weather and of course he
didn't care about the weather because it
didn't matter he could throw it anything
yeah right
but there's the stories about Brett and
just between Brett and his father yeah
they went a championship game he changed
the play they score they win the
championship state championship I think
they're celebrating on the field and
bread just gets knocked from the side it
goes to the ground his dad's on top of
him eagles return what the hell you
doing change in my place yeah yeah I
want to see it too actually
that dad has some great stories I don't
expect him to share but dad has great
stories of his days covering games when
he used to go up to Green Bay and have
to talk to Brett on a Saturday or Friday
and Brett is hilarious and I know we're
not going to share them here but they're
they're pretty damn funny we're not yes
no he we would talk to him for an hour
and we would not say one word about
football
word that was the last thing he was
gonna talk about man I'll talk about us
stupid game I'm gonna go play nine holes
I get done with you guys so that's why
Barney Bernstein was our sideline
reporter and she's Wilkins well Brett
you know she asked him a football
question and he just kind of went like
what was that what do you talk about
yeah it was like we told her to he's not
gonna answer football questions and of
course it was everything the stories he
had pictures he wants to show you yeah I
am a dick in Berg you know who was the
most proper man in the world and a lot
of fun to work with I mean he was
hilarious
and he would you know throw some jabs in
on the air
inside jokes and you go wow that was you
know pretty good stuff right I wish I
could talk about it but I can't fun
that's for sure yeah Phil we're gonna
get you drunk and you're gonna tell
these stories on the podcast it's gonna
be all oh no I would never do that
because they're private yeah that's
right their profits he's a journalist
yeah that's right you know yeah they're
they're private I don't want to I would
never do that and Brett what even Brett
wouldn't want me to tell him on you know
yeah public Terry sold those same
stories he told them to everybody and
they were well I don't know they were
crazy yeah Billie O'Dell he what's going
on there you know the draft I think Josh
Arlen is probably going to be drafted in
the seventh round that's not accurate
maybe he might be a high priority free
agent he's not accurate enough he'd only
just see this he just I hate that just
yeah he's great but he's just so good I
could tell dad's ready to go dog don't
shoot all your bones to the quarterback
thing we're gonna have yeah and you and
I talked about it
right Adam on the Monday before the
draft I think we're gonna I'm definitely
filming a draft show for CBS okay and
CBS Sports is probably going to come on
that Monday night I didn't ask for scum
on that night but I'm gonna fire some
bullets whoa preemptive Phil called a
shot this is this is gonna be great
all right writing down a list the show
needs to be six hours you want a therapy
session not a TV show I like okay I'm my
own therapist you know I'll talk to
myself we're good at that we're sins are
good at that what they're about must sit
there go yeah okay right yeah all right
get the hell out of here we're time I
just got one thing right okay if you're
gonna call me at 4:15 let's try to be
somewhere within 20 minutes of it either
way okay
I know it's left ko he's the worst it's
me he's the one that schedules the show
and he packs it and thinks it's gonna
fit in an hour and then we're already at
an hour and 20 right now five minutes we
could get it in there just don't make
anything all right we'll talk to you
next week see Dad see okay so there's a
segment there no it's called it's called
big Phil talks about like New Age
feelings because his take on therapists
is embed you he went to a therapy
session he would give therapy to the
therapy Oh God what you need to do is
honestly I'm sitting away you're sitting
there right now I know I have an
old-school relationship with my wife
okay
like we've taught you know we do we have
an old-school relationship we're very
and we got our terms a settlement right
yes you want to see old school I mean
you want to see archaic go see Phil and
Diana okay
I mean freaking film when we were
growing up when we went on family
vacations he wouldn't even go with us he
would make my mom take us down he would
go first and make you know I'm gonna go
down play a few rounds golf yeah I'll
see you guys down there so he never had
to go through the pains of being the
father never he was ever in the airport
with he's never like in the plane with
us and like you know like I was like
eight years old and my sister's forward
Matt's crying in the plane like he was
never down like he was never there
that's why the response therapy units
there all right it's time about
quarterbacks with Chris Sims water BX he
has gone back for the first time he's
looked at all the quarterbacks he is
rallying reevaluated and there are
legitimate changes yeah before we get
going
Oklahoma State quarterback is he close
to the five no he's not he is not
Mountain Mason Rudolph I don't think
he's a second-round pick in my eyes to
me just too stiff not a good enough
thrower not a good enough athlete in the
pocket okay
that would be my biggest thing in fact
the two oklahoma state guys in general
him and the kid James Washington I was
very disappointed when I watched them
James Washington I was really expecting
something he really just happens to
catch a poster out against the right
cover
from time to time he really can't do a
whole lot else other than that but yeah
masonry us not really that guy I'm in
early levels of some of those later guys
like listen to me us uh uh if you're
looking to get a quarterback in the
second or third way you go for the guy
that you go okay it might not look
perfect on the field but this guy could
be something got you he's guy I don't
want a guy that goes whoa
he's a backup for ten years I want to
get a guy to go he's our backup to start
but we think he could be a starter and
two or three types of video three years
ago when the Chiefs drafted Aaron Murray
that's the WR sitting there there's
enough there to go and me and Miller was
the only time that I've yelled at Miller
on camera and I was and he was like he
could be chased Daniel Wright I was like
why do you take chase Daniel Wright why
not take an actual player that could do
something exactly rabbits who is the new
Sims number five quarterback that was
Sol a batard that was who is was it
that's how he did the setup for
everything on the list no number five
quarterback according to crew Sims of
lechero Hart guys number five what we
hope what was your original list I'm
gonna pull out right now my original is
like I texted Mar Josh Baker your
original Liz Rosen Lamar it was Lamar
Jackson Josh Alan Baker Mayfield Sam
Darnell Josh Rose right so you had Josh
Rosen at five right who is number five
in your fans Arnold is the fifth best
quarterbacks and our number one pick
this is where I'm sure on the kalaiy
know people are gonna sit your sock jock
listen I'm not I'm just telling you I'm
studying this and I just again a
first-round quarterback without a doubt
I'm not arguing that but the fact that
he's talked about is this slam dunk
number one or number two pick I don't
get it so go ahead I've gone through
your notes yeah here were your notes
when you watch the first three game
right you're not a big fan of us motion
there's no denying that he's a baller I
can spin it he can make all the throws
he's got average arm strength
he throws well in the run he throws old
footballs though it's something to be
scared of right doesn't have a variety
of passes due to the west coast
offence fumbles are an issue almost
always throws to his first read right
that was when you had him at four upon
further review right no you went back
and watch what third down snap watch
yeah I watched third down snaps clutch
drives touchdown passes interceptions
and like two extra games I went deep I
don't think I've ever gotten this deep
anymore that for each of them each so
here's what the further review gave you
one third down when Sam Darnell has to
stand in the pocket he's not a great
thrower unless the first option is open
right he want whenever you want to jump
in with like a big pointer he once he
actually wants the pocket to break down
I'm so underwhelmed with his throwing in
the pocket yeah he doesn't fit it into
tight windows and when he tries it's
trouble almost always throws behind
receivers when driving it and then in
all caps there is no way he is the
number one pick he really doesn't
anticipate throws all of his throws
outside the numbers are very average he
plays a college style and I'm not sure
it translates to the NFL yes
okay so remember some of those there I'm
gonna try to go through all that a
little bit but I might miss a spot here
or there
okay I mean that was very negative it
was negative because the third down tape
after I watched a few extra games and
watched the Texas game which listen
again he made some good plays in the
Texas game and the third down tape is
valuable because the defense is
anticipating a pass
there's no that's the reason it's it's
telling third down is where you make
your money in the NFL Puteri goals were
number one so Tom Brady's good on third
down every year insurers down Sam
Darnell you learned because you learn a
lot because the defense does different
things right they're creative they go
they're gonna pass we're gonna give us
different looks different blitzes
different coverages everything like that
you're there's no the play-action pass
is no longer a viable option the sprint
out throat is no longer an option unless
it's third and short so you're watching
and what are you seeing I'm watching in
going
first of all I'll stand by my original
thing he's the worst in the pocket out
of all these quarterbacks it's very
concerning reenactment well I mean in
the pocket it's it's a little bit like
this that the first guy's not wide open
it becomes drop the ball and start
looking to move around and look at her
and then some a lot of those times he
makes a nice little play and you go oh
man that wasn't he got out of some
trouble and threw a 10 yard pass but my
big thing would be personally didn't
have to leave the pocket and a lot of
times when you look at it he turns down
open receivers down the field because
now he's looked at the first guy and he
wasn't open he's gonna dance around the
pocket and then you know I've heard a
lot of people go well he throws well
under pressure yes he does but I've said
to you before he is the reason for a lot
of the pressure he moves himself into it
a lot of the time in the pressure he is
by far the worst seer of the field and
those situations to a lot of dropped
interceptions when you watch say Madonna
let alone the fumbles and everything
like it and my big thing too is again
we've talked about this as years past
and I think this is what became more
relevant to me the second time around
just a little bit like some of his most
amazing physical plays are just against
crap pac-12 teams
I mean the pac-12 are we talking about
any defender in the first round on the
pac-12 who is the Brazilian but except
for vitae via at the Washington
defensive line to do it I left the top
in my head right now I can't even think
of a defensive player that we're talking
about in the first run of the pac-12 the
pac-12 stinks yeah it stinks the safety
from Stanford maybe he's another guy
that can be a first rounder okay that
just popped in my head but so so how are
we getting to this narrative that he's
them I don't know I do think like
Danielle Jeremiah and Joe clot need to
be a little embarrassed with their
breakdown a quarterback's I don't even
want to get too deep into that it does
Bobby I'm gonna say about Joe cloud has
he had deshone Kizer is his number one
quarterback right that tells you a lot
the way he talked after the same Donald
just comparing him to Roy Hobbs and the
Raymond saying that he's a physically
gifted a horses are dropping balls and
then they're throwing showing a
Highlander is a ball 20 years of this
this is an exercise for Simms and Lefko
fans we do not make stuff up to get hits
we don't Sims is just different and
that's just the fact but do this go to
YouTube watch Sam Darnell's Pro Day it's
not that great because all these
networks zoom in and they don't show you
the whole field but watch his pro day
look at the throws in which he misses
guys and then listen if the announcers
mention it because they never do
the other thing I'll say is this the USC
connection with Sam Darnell is very
interested it's very deep detailing for
everybody ok sure all right so first of
all it starts like this I think that the
people you're hearing the most like love
of Sam Donald is he is a Southern Cal
crowd you know first of all the
Cleveland Browns Hugh Jackson's the
number one pick he's he's Southern Cal
guy who also coached at USC who's
training him Palmer oh you mean Carson
Palmer's brother who also went to USC
okay so there's that and a lot of people
are talking to Jordan Palmer to get
inside know about it no doubt about it
then there's the Daniel Jeremiah you
know where he's from
I don't Southern California Colin
Cowherd Joel e.classname west coast
right yes now Colin Cowherd of course is
out on the west coast and then LA he's
you just want to say one thing to people
I just think it's a little bit biased
because of the emblem on the helmet and
he's a handsome guy
I think the chin plays a part into this
I think bias plays a part in to this and
I also say this you throw in the rain
not only to show people that you can
throw in the rain but when you miss
throws guess what you can blame right
the rain the rain so and you know whose
setup Blake bortles Pro day yeah right
and so what did he do with what he
didn't play that with Josh Allen no so
but we'll go with that in a second but
Blake bortles his pro day was like 99%
down just remains and backs out of the
backfield
so he went let me find the one day it's
gonna rain it's a good no that's his job
Jordan Palmer did his job listen and
again Donald did some good things in the
workout is good that he threw the ball
in the rain but this is again let me
just make these last points okay first
of all I out of these quarterbacks what
does he do the best I don't think
there's anything maybe improvised maybe
improvised maybe but that's really hard
to say when Lamar Jackson's in this
conversation maybe he's a so but either
way maybe it is up there leader he's
loved by his team there's no off the
field that we have to talk about that a
little with all these guys
here's off the field of squeaky clean I
know that all but so he's he's truly
loved the team loves them oh that's
right you have notes from people that
you talked yet today will go to war for
him like he is lost by his team so it is
valuable that is value and he is young
and he can get better so again I'm not
sitting you're just a crap I just don't
understand the number one number two
pick I do worry about the style of play
in which he plays
is it really realistic in the NFL like I
said a lot of the great athletic place
come against teams that are not very
good
they don't come against Ohio State or
the Notre Dame's of the world and this
is what bothers me to see for whatever
reason he gets the benefit in those
games I hear it all the time well Ohio
State they were just so overmatched but
but none of the other quarterbacks seem
to get that benefit of the doubt shall
we roast for getting destroyed by Iowa
it looks like there wasn't a player on
Josh Allen's team that could make the
Iowa roster but know you'll hear people
just watch that Iowa game and I'll make
you change your mind well I watched The
Ohio State Notre Dame game and man it
stunk and the reason they were in the
hole a lot of them did jot did Darnell
make some good throws yeah but the
reason they were in the hole in those
games was cause of Sam darn old I mean I
was on the field at Notre Dame I mean he
fumbled he fumbled in exchange with a
running back he missed a wide open post
for a touchdown that under threw it and
the guy didn't even get it did he get to
catch it the Ohio State game
it was interceptions it was pick six but
the stats at the end of the game look
okay and I think that's again where he
go oh he made some plays see great he
made some plays when they were down 28
to nothing and the emotion that was out
of the game and the defense was in
pre-event mode I mean that doesn't count
to me so those are my concerns yes
because I think he's the first round he
is definitely a first rounder but I'm
just I'm straight Harrison um number one
number two lock I don't see it I'm sorry
right here guys
we're not afraid to tell you the truth
the players podcast will never stay
you're wrong
you had darn 'old at four and you had
Rosen at five do you have Rosen it for
who is your number four know who is your
number four quarterbacks okay number
four this is really close between four
and three okay I'm gonna go four is
Lamar Jackson I'm cowboy oh this is a
member of the team Lamar Park total team
Lamar just calm down
we're team Lamar you say you're number
one quarterback Sanger number four he is
yes yeah I know
I'm sorry let me read you wrote okay all
right so what you had written about
Lamar Jackson Here I am
roasting other people for changing it
well I
using your overfloor elite athlete great
change of direction throwing motion is
effortless he can spin it legs are too
stiff though when he throws good deep
ball accuracy pretty good
decision-making incompletions are on
target most of the time what the [ __ ]
Bill Polian throws well with people
around him almost unstoppable in the red
zone you went back you watched third
down and you watched someone with
Carolina State I watched Wake Forest
game to add on to that and I watched oh
the Mississippi State game that's
knocked him out of the drafts I mean
he's out of the draft because a
Mississippi State game except he made
like four plays that nobody on planet
earth can make so I'm knocking him out
all right upon further review [ __ ] piss
me off
I hear that damn comment one more time
to go ahead upon for the review doesn't
always give wide receiver a chance on
5050 balls
don't forget pass protection is
consistently horrible damn he turned the
corner on Derwin James is it perfect no
but a holy crap that he makes some
big-time effin plays and throws in the
end of North Carolina State Boston
College in Florida State worst talent
around him other than Josh Allen he is
being unfairly judged in my opinion yes
but I need to know why you went from one
before what the number one to four
because I think of just other
inconsistencies I see throughout the
film and then the off the field stuff is
going to knock him down for me it has to
a little bit it has to switch off the
field so let me just say this I am a
huge believer in Lamar Jackson he just
the most raw of the group to a degree
okay the off the field stuff that
bothers me is this his mom's is agent
okay nobody can get in contact with him
I mean I tried texting her today I mean
Michael Vick he just made a comment
yesterday I've tried to get in contact
with Lamar jacks I can't get ahold of
them okay so that's scary that's scary
the relationship between him and his old
head coach
patrina at Reno I heard his gun to the
dump okay okay he wasn't great on the
board and in meetings and things like
that his like best friend from growing
up is training him for the combine so I
when I connect dots like that they do
scare me listen that's the way it is I
don't think this kid is stupid by any
stretch of the imagination so I don't
want to hear that talk right you're not
challenging isn't allowed not changing
these decisions are like end up I'm
seeing a pattern I'm seeing
pattern and the fact that I know from
multiple teams that he wasn't the most
impressive on the board and things like
that okay it doesn't still doesn't mean
anything I know that his offense is more
complex than Sam Donaldson USC he's
capable of learning in offense maybe he
just learns a little different than the
rest of the guys right which is very
capable too so those things concern me
out of the fact when I turn on the film
like the first time around I watched the
Clemson game I watched the Boston
College game he made great plays in the
Boston College game the Clemson game he
missed some throws but they were
severely overmatched just like Sam
Donald was and then right USC Ohio State
came and he missed the rose and I just
said oh well you know better for the
duck did and what happened is I went
when I watch other games where he did
play well he still was inconsistent on
throws that were I was just like damn
like no you got to hit that but you're
not just whether it was hitch routes out
into the flat like 6-yard curl routes
where the guy just six routes turns
around or maybe a 10-yard curl route
same type of thing where yeah there's
moments where the ball is a little all
over the place and it's praised and I
don't know if there's a true mechanic
that he relies on yet as a thrower he
kind of just gets it done which is a
positive because it shows you he's a
natural thrower but you do need a
mechanic at times because even Tiger
Woods messes up on the driver down the
fare wood right you gotta have something
to rely on that day where you go oh I
don't have it it sounds like you so
believe he has a really high ceiling
unbelievably I just want to make sure it
just sounds like the floor has gone down
because of all the things that have
happened and I think I wanted to [ __ ] on
Bill Polian so badly and when it came
out I couldn't and I got excited about
the talent because his film is
phenomenal fun to watch I mean it's
phenomenal yeah if there's so much good
in it so far I don't want to hear this
right now I'm hearing this I'm hearing
he's not making great decisions off the
field with the business right like which
scares you rise of acclimating to a
profession exactly right you're seeing
some easy throws that aren't there that
you build on in an office right it
sounds like mechanically it's kind of
like a shooter in basketball that he's a
really good shooter right but you're
like Lonzo ball you're like that's not
gonna work yeah you can't keep doing
that always right yeah you can maybe
fine-tune it but I don't know you're
saying that the relationship with the
former coach isn't great how will he
take two coaches either right there's a
lot of questions
exactly right but he's kind of a quiet
guy and all that he's not your typical
like alpha male you know quarterback
who's like I comes in the room he's
Johnny charismatic and he got you you
know swindles and dwindles everybody's a
player yeah he's got a quarter he is
he's a football player okay so that's
where the concern is but again the kids
a quarterback let's just make that clear
he's a first-round quarterback without a
doubt for me a first rounder yes there's
you know like okay there's other things
to like just like some quarterback
design run plays I could show you a few
place where he ran the wrong way that's
gonna be concerning like they're gonna
look at the film ago oh wait no the
guard pulled right the other guard
pulled right the backs going right he
went left so those are other little
things that you just go and go damn like
it's not the end of the world so who do
you want to see teaching this kid what
coaches would really anybody's gonna be
on [ __ ] it doesn't even matter
I don't even don't have to look them up
because I just again I've I've heard
this story again this is where I want to
shut all this [ __ ] okay
I'm sorry I'm swearing too much on this
one but I'm heated about Lamar I want to
shut it all on the mark well I mean I
heard the stories a little about the
deshaun Watson who were concerned about
the throwing I heard this a little bit
about you know dak Prescott I heard a
little bit about Cam Newton you know I
just feel like I've heard the story and
then they get in the pros and they get
around coaching and they have coaches
around them all day and then get reps
and they get somebody on top of them
without mechanics all the time there's
no 20 hour rule like the NCAA and they
get better because they were good
already they just needed a little
fine-tuning so that's where I get it
yeah and again if we want to talk about
hey he threw four picks against
Mississippi State yeah you know two were
really bad throws one was like two were
bad decisions one was like the right
decision he just threw a bad ball behind
a receiver and then another one went
right through the receivers hands right
so it was four interceptions but gosh
damn it did he not make some of the most
unbelievable damn plays I've ever seen
in the game two throws and runs I mean
I've seen him I've seen him running
around Bradley Chubb I've seen him run
around Durham on James yeah I've seen
him run down 90 yards Mississippi State
who nobody runs 90 yards on them yeah so
Derwin James we were sitting in the
green room he's a beast and we're
talking about like quarterbacks and
stuff right
he without even being talked about Coast
and I can't believe they're talking this
stuff about Lamar Jess he goes I faced
everybody he goes he's an NFL
quarterback right he goes out he goes
you figure out a way to make that happen
well like in his face like his eyes so
again they're gonna talk about losses
and all that to like like I told the
fartist a game they won but he also
threw two game-winning touchdown passes
that were dropped he threw some big
passes the end of the Boston College
game one which was dropped but then even
the final fumble that ended the game
where they were gonna drive down and
score he threw a great pass receivers
running down the field there in middle
midfield he fumbles Boston College gets
the ball they win the game so there's
plenty to see of great plays in the
clutch so again he's my number four
would you draft him oh I think he's a if
you're in the right team in the right
situation I would have no issue if like
you know you look at teams like all of
the who is it where the Cardinals at 15
if they felt like you know we're willing
to take this year on the chin for a
little development with him and we got
Sam Bradford go for it this guy could be
could he play right away though is there
a situation yes yes but I think do think
that's where you would need ache I would
love to see it if you ended up in
Jacksonville where you can run an RPO
offense can be simple and you just go
wear boots
we're play actions he'll make some plays
with his legs and their unfortunately
they trade it for Cody Kessler's so
again I don't I know I draw I dropped
them but I really believe in this kid I
just want to make sure that's known
you're just seeing a lot I'm just saying
I don't think you can take him before
these next three yet because of the
Lau's issues and that means that rosin
continues to rise so rosin was before
your top five was Lamar Jackson Josh
Allen Mayfield Arnold Rosen Jackson is
now four darn 'old is now five you had
Mayfield at three last time who is three
this time Mayfield is three so he
remains he remains but I'm innocent to
say this I think it's closer between
Baker and Lamar - I do I mean I do Baker
Mayfield you brought to us last time
pretty flawless throwing mechanics
motion feet remind you of Favre Oklahoma
offense is tough they're really good in
the big 12 sucks but he's great in the
pocket yeah
upon further review went back you
watched more games who watch third down
and some game-winning drives is what you
came out with although a lot of
impressive throws not a lot of realistic
NFL throws on obvious passing situations
he doesn't stand in there and make as
many big throws his decision-making is a
little concerning - on third down the
advantage disappears and he's not as
impressive when the pocket caves in he
panics a little he can't see any one's
to escape his best third down throws our
three step quick throws and the scramble
plays are not realistic in the NFL
because it's not against NFL talent
right I found your review of Baker to be
the most different from the first time
yeah I feel like you went back and
watched and when I got jobs by a little
bit I kind of got got I got got because
I think the first time around he's just
he was a little better than I was
expecting right and he threw the ball
and it fell level he's definitely on NFL
arm though definitely yes so that I
think all that but then as I started to
watch more in it and the first time I
ran I think I expressed concern that he
gets a lot of easy throws and there's
people wide open and that's still an
issue for me because like I said not
realistic NFL third down throws the guy
I don't get to see a lot of the hard
thing about Mayfield and Arnold is
they're both guys who like to escape and
create yeah at the NFL level they're not
getting away like the old Johnny Manziel
thing oh well he can scramble but then
when they play LSU in Florida he could
never scramble why because they NFL
defense ends and linebackers were like
what you run for seven nine big deal
okay right so Baker though so Baker
there's still a lot of good there okay
first of all off the field it's he's
squeaky as they get I heard a story from
I think it was Hugh Jackson right where
he solved he saw like him with the
entire to the team at Oklahoma and he
was like he he something like that and
the whole team was like he and they all
like followed him out and he was like it
was the most incredible thing I've he's
loved he is loved only issued the Baker
Mayfield is maybe the cockiness thing
right that people were whatever but
whatever but I'm just tell you this like
people I've talked to they can't find
anybody to say anything bad about the
kid gotcha
right so that's a create he is loved
like a team trainers equipment guy the
only thing was the crotch
against kids right I know oh no like so
horrible gosh a guy 19 years old if he
did that and there wasn't a camera on
him we would have never known
no no exactly right it's the media it is
the media yeah I think again I think the
big thing is the I do worry about the
realistic nosov his style of play the
size does concern me it does because you
can see in certain situations when a
defense knows he's gonna pass and if he
can't kind of escape yeah that he's not
gonna be able to see down the field can
he make some of those big power throws
with people in his face and like just
flick it on a comeback route or a thing
like that yeah I think all that is just
question marks that I have and yeah I'm
not sure about it again you know like
like I said like I always compared to a
Russell Wilson coming out you know you
hear the drew brees stuff I don't think
he's quite a good athlete as I thought
he was I think the more I watched the
first time around he's quick and he can
move in the pocket yeah you know but
like it also scares me drew please Andy
Roddick and man-to-man
I mean one-on-one tennis he did yeah I
mean Russell Wilson was I mean he's
Russell Wilson he's playing for the
Yankees spare exactly I mean he was
playing that's the thing that's oh it's
not quite where I start comparing him to
that right whenever you compare someone
to outliers yeah I get scared yeah I
hear you that's there you go you're
comparing him to people that bucked the
trend yes and that's a hard thing all
right so but what about Baker at 3 to
the Jets does that make sense in your
mind right it could it does make sense
yes ok I have no issue with that Baker's
of the other you have these questions
going number three is still ok because i
oh yeah it is it's ok I mean if a team
feels that close then why is Lamar at 15
and he's at 3 yeah because I think Baker
is probably a little more polished all
together to where you can just trust it
from anyone more than the human being
aspects yes exactly that's what I mean
just so I'm talking about all of it all
together Jeremy Bates the offensive
coordinator for the Houston I mean the
New York Jets who I was with in Tampa I
just again don't know this but being
around that person I would think Baker
Mayfield would be his type of guy ok ok
that's the other just line I'll draw
there I don't know any of that of course
but yeah if that happens sure
Baker's also the guy that I could think
like damn he could fall out of the top
ten - I can see him being the one out of
these like everybody talking about the
big four nobody's including Lamar which
i think is annoying isn't that
interesting yeah it's annoying but I do
think out of those guys Baker could be
the guy to fall a little bit because
people are gonna get concerned about the
size and okay you're that size and he
ran for eight so nobody's gonna go oh
you're Russell Wilson right so before
you had the big three and in the bottom
two yeah you had the more Josh and Baker
on their own playing field and then you
had Rosen and Arnold kind of on the
bottom darn 'old stayed down there it
seems like Lamar and Baker have both
kind of come down as you've done more
evaluation yeah are you going to sit
here and tell me that Josh Rosen is now
your number one quarterback no I'm not
okay okay all right but Josh Rosen has
gone from five to two yeah and you know
it's interesting when Sims gave us his
quarterback rankings the first time
there was one quarterback that I said I
think he got him too low you did that
was Josh Rosen yeah
Adam left go back whisper when I said
something to when I got done with doing
rose and I think I did rose in Friday
afternoon I was like ooh Rosen's better
than I gave him credit for the first
time around he was like Oh see told you
to party you had written about Rosen
yeah great in the pocket not a great
athlete yeah offense has the most Pro
concepts out of all these guys great
touch and anticipation good but not
special arm reminds me of Eli and
Glennon can be surgical if in the right
system went back watched the third down
snaps watched some big games and some
big drives and Chris Sims came out with
this man his feet are slow and his
delivery can be at times as well he
won't make many plays off schedule but
if he has time in a window he'll make it
love the way he throws it love the way
he sees the field it's alarming though
that he can't scramble and avoid rushers
in the pocket his mechanics are flawless
he is truly the opposite of Sam Darnell
he is he's like the opposite guy he's
bizarro Sam door he is because he's
comfortable in the pocket he's not
really great at improvising
if the throw needs to be made he can
make it and Arnold is like I like chaos
I want to roll out
but I'll do like a jump pass whatever it
is exactly right to play backyard
football this is the yeah the exact
opposite and I don't think Donald was
that much faster in the 40 though he
wasn't no and don't I mean yeah I would
say this the first time around
Rosen's a little bit better athlete than
I gave him credit for
yeah five to two I think what happened
is the more I watched it I just felt
like man you know the lack of
athleticism is concerning to me but
there's nothing else on the field like
everything else you kind of checked the
boxes with and I think he got in that
and I sat there and I was just like okay
like hold on here like just think about
all this let me think about all the
flaws the other guys have and I'm just
talking about this guy this is the only
flaw he has and it is an important flaw
and his off the field stuff is a little
concerning which stuff it's half and
half I mean what are you hearing I mean
people think he's a douche yeah there's
no other way to put it
you know yeah there's a lot of douches
in Iowa I know I'm just telling you
that's true for me where'd you hear that
what does that make you I don't know
what the thing cuz I know it can go all
over the place in the NFL it could just
be the way you think people call you
that when you were I'm sure they did
like I told you I had some teams tell me
that no we thought you were a party boy
and I just got that's hilarious cuz did
my friends at Texas thought I was a nerd
that stayed home and watched Shrek on
Friday no I just feel like Rosen if he's
if he's that kind of comment party boy
to them because they saw me on 6th
Street one time in there but do you
think going to an NFL locker room
humbles people immediately definitely
well I don't think that's the issue with
him I think it's like team tee you know
people within the UCLA whether it be
players or even other people around it
don't love them so what his name came
out who was the coach at UCLA there's
questions
Jim Mora right so hasn't he crapped on
players before he has I believe yes like
he's the last guy he crapped on I feel
like he had one where he's like was it
wasn't Anthony bar or there was somebody
else I know we're missing somebody else
right how was it look at this but either
way yeah I saw what he said well yeah he
obviously Josh Rosen's rubbed him the
wrong way yeah I mean that was a low
blow towards Josh Rosen there was sam
donald first and say he's the guy
so again listen i think at the end of
the day
the decision-making the throwing the
ability to throw the ball down the field
it's all there was a beautiful deep
beautiful deep ball and his arm stronger
than I think I gave it credit for it I
wish he would like rip and do it a
little bit more at times but I think
that could be also like to show in
Watson last year where if he has to and
he's around it a little more I think
it's there the big issue with him will
be that I know there's some teams that
question if he really loves football
which was always a little alarming to me
like what do you mean like because I've
been around guys who like they like
playing but they don't want to do the
other stuff to work I don't think that's
the here's the problem saying somebody
doesn't love football right when he sits
in front of you and goes I love football
you can't take him at his word there's
literally nothing he can do to prove to
anybody that that's not true I saw him
on the Rich Eisen show I saw him say
this is all I want to do yeah I gave up
a promising tennis career to go out
there and get my head bashed in because
I love football and people are still
gonna go yeah but I think he's just
saying that I know I don't think it's
possible for it I think once you get
that it's like this dark cloud that's
right with Kaepernick I don't really
know if he wants to play or if he just
wants to continue with civil civil right
movement right okay so what could he do
to prove it yeah nothing I know so I
don't listen to that I get you I'm just
telling you pieces that I've heard and
I'm just trying to take it all into
account yeah okay the other thing that
I'm thinking is okay so if you remind
you of Eli and he's surgical if he has
time why not bring him to the team that
already has Eli that you're can you can
build around one guy and it'll be a
seamless transition to the replacement
yeah sure I mean it makes sense from
that I get that I totally feel yeah I
mean that's that's the kind of guy he is
if Rosen comes to New York oh I am
taking him to Murray's bagels before are
you about to move to the next
quarterback yes before we get there you
did think that this was gonna be the
number one all along right like the
first go-around you were surprised that
this guy thought Josh Allen was your
number one I mean you anytime you
watched him during the season you were
amazed and and now he's definitely the
number one definitely definitely the
number one yes I'm just reading my notes
again just to make sure if I didn't miss
anything with Josh Allen anything else
there's Rose Rosen sorry well I'm just
kidding so he's near number two he is my
number two
the one I feel most comfortable about
where I just go if we went oh that's
where I would a bit like if you're
drafting right okay and I just said
everything was equal right like okay we
have a team that really needs a
quarterback yeah and our team's not
great but it's good or great you know
what I mean like I just looked at him
and said no he's a guy I think out of
all those that you can plug him in
pretty quick and he's gonna go in there
and be pretty successful Josh Allen you
had originally written a writ incredible
arm insanely basic offense no talent
around him fairly good mechanics that
need to be cleaned up
reminds me of whence it went back watch
more games third downs drives third down
tape upon further review he is
incredibly elusive and fearless in the
pocket makes so many big-time NFL throws
and almost all are under pressure with
arm and size he is gonna be a beast on
third down the NFL he is such a good
athlete his biggest problem is on touch
throws or short check down type throws
you are only emboldened in believing
that Josh Allen is the number one yes I
am and again I think the the so many
people think that he's just not good
yeah I don't really understand it you
know I don't there are the same people
that think Sam dartle is one so what do
you think that tells you I don't know I
mean first of all let's just start out
with the pro day the pro day was one of
the best pro days I've ever seen why
because it was just one big time throw
it after another he didn't do anything
like he didn't throw seven swing rats to
go oh he was 58 or 60 in his workout
today against nobody and you know 30 of
those completions were for four yards or
less like if I have to see you throw a
four yard throw like too many times and
I don't even want to go to the workout
well I didn't come there to see you
check the ball down to the back like
come on I want to see a few okay sure
just got a flow after that I want to see
legit and I bought the Rose I want to
see slants out routes come backs in cuts
deep post play actions off schedule
scramble set up throw the ball his his
work as you saw yeah it was like Carson
Wentz er Jameis Winston back in the day
it was real and ifelse wasn't let's hide
the agenda I want you to think about
this right if I am planning Chris Simms
as Pro Day I am gonna focus on the
things that you do well and
minimize the things that you don't do it
yes Carson Palmer's brother Jordan
Palmer Wright is the coach for both Sam
Darnell and Josh Allen yeah
if Josh Allen goes out there and just
throws it deep and makes all the throws
that means that Jordan Palmer said well
I want to show off his skill set and I'm
gonna focus on the real NFL throws when
Sam darn 'old goes out there and throws
a ton of check downs and is doing foot
drills to show his footwork and then
occasionally throws deep throws that
means that his coach believed that he
needed to show all that other eck and
have it in the rain because he didn't
believe that he could do all the throws
at Josh Allen I'm look how do you that's
how I'm looking no I think it's a lot of
property you got like it you got it you
got a look at you can cook with the
ingredients that you have so if Sam darn
'old isn't throwing as hard a throws or
difficult throws at Josh Allen does then
he doesn't have the ingredients than
Josh Allen has that's all we need a
standardized product some type of some
type of organization that standardizes
the workouts are better because the
teams then make you do the work because
because otherwise do you remember the
talk about Johnny Manziel the music yet
pads yeah he's a gamer he's a leader he
called over all of the NFL coaches and
gave them a speech before he threw and
people are like I feel I felt it I felt
the energy that's not why you're here
now just watch the arm all right so it's
just for TV it's just an ESPN NFL
Network thing let's watch it on Jordan
Palmer Jordan Palmer's house his jobs
get paid that's when he gets paid the
man yeah all right Jordan's the man Josh
Allen just yeah you're that much more
confident now yeah I am I mean I think
the things that put it over the top for
me or the combine first of all off the
field
squeaky okay so that just gets he's good
don't worry about that and then yes
between the combine and his pro day my
biggest concerns were his motion gets a
little long and that's why the ball can
spray at times I'm still waiting to see
my first non spiral throw post after the
season because every ball is just the
absolute piss missile oh yeah worked on
it I saw tons of touch throws okay so
he's learned
little mechanics of what to do in the
touch throws and it's stuck from the
combine into the pro day so that tells
me that it's ingrained in him already I
don't have to worry about like it's Tim
T but we didn't have to make a huge
adjustment to his motion it was just a
little tweak but yes the athleticism the
amount of big time throws really
decision-making is pretty good no easy
completions like I told you playing up
in the I mean he's playing up in the
North Pole up there I mean there's
there's a game the game I watched in the
blizzard um I mean he played in a
blizzard I had to turn it off because I
couldn't see but I kept going to M he
completed it but I can't really see the
ball so I had to go to other games that
the ability to escape the pocket and
move around I mean he's only he's second
to Lamar Jackson in that category I mean
he's the best the second best athlete of
the group per his combine results or
just watching him run around you can
tell it's natural it's easy for him I
just I I don't I think he's like the
safest pick because also I think his
floor is like his floor is like he's
middle of the NFL starting quarterback I
mean what's there to say his for is I I
don't want to hear about the completion
percentage no screens every ball he
throws his aggressive down the field and
he was always talking to downs always no
a second third and long
I mean his receivers couldn't get open
against you and I truly mean that yeah
there so I really like his game and his
skill set and I think he's I pretty much
can't miss yeah who has the highest
ceiling of the five highest ceiling of
the five if they reach their absolute
max potential okay it's between Allen
and Lamar Jackson right it's one of
those two I mean Allen I mean Lamar can
be like he could be Michael Vick or
better I mean he can be that kind of guy
he really can it's gonna it's gonna be
up to him from here on out how good he
wants to be and what's big high ceiling
PP sit man Josh Allen can be like a I
don't even know where I've said from the
start like he's a more athletic Troy
Aikman
that's who you reminded me are on the
day I saw him is his Troy Aikman except
he's got looser hips and can turn it on
and he's actually gotten even a stronger
arm than Troy did in his prime so ma'am
yes
what I look at him is like like alright
you know it sees he's impressive man
yeah they don't build them like that too
often I'll say this the reason that I'm
very excited about this draft is
typically it's Jamis or Mariota and then
we forget right or we look at these
other quarter Bisons Wentz or golf and
then we forget this one was a legit year
yeah of analyzing all of the
quarterbacks
it reminds me a lot of the bortles teddy
Manziel Derek Carr year which who was
your number one that you're Derek Carr
so what I like about Garoppolo is my
second I think you're right yeah so eat
that so what I like about this is guys
go to these websites take screenshots
you feel confident about yours I might
are not changing like I told you they're
not that's Josh Allen just amrosen
I mean Josh so Josh Allen Josh Rosen
Baker Mayfield Lamar Jackson Sam dong
damn dog the only I don't want to put it
up against anybody willing to put it up
against tiny put this out for you you do
not everybody wants to bet against Simms
if anybody wants to bet against it I'll
do it left goes take an action I don't
take an action but Lamar Baker thing I
think as close to them people getting
credit but my biggest three and four
could flip it's not gonna flip though
it's not I'm gonna stay there but I'm
just saying it's very close my biggest
thing is this this is my I just don't
understand the same d'arnot's definitely
one or two I don't get it that it just I
just don't
so I'll say that I've been around it my
whole life
you can call me what you want I know I
might be an [ __ ] at my feet you want
action you come and bet again let's go
I didn't make the 5 but I'm willing to
bet okay Sophia if any of you so-called
bloviator shoot talking heads you think
you're so cocky you think you're so
confident I'll backhand these
quarterbacks let me take some yeah I got
a little wild card name Sims I locked
him in a room with footage and he came
out with that top five I'll put it
against your top five for any money you
want the auricle camera guys are like
are you freaking kidding me come on four
sips peace out homies forfend Rick good
evening everybody glad I came back for
the end so am i that was soon as its
quarterback a list by the time we come
back on Monday
Odell
could be playing for the Niners man
that's where you're guessing the Niners
that's what you're rooting for um I
guess I'm rooting for that too yeah
trade for oh and that is the lef koe man
that will holler at you guys later guys
have a great weekend love you very long
time